[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Hi,
this is Natalie Villalobos
from Big Android
BBQ in Hurst, Texas,
and I'm here with Marie Schweiz.
She is a visiting designer.
She's a speaker here
at Big Android BBQ,
and I wanted to just
get some inside tips,
so that all designers
of the world
know how to best
design for Android.
Welcome, Marie.
MARIE SCHWEIZ: Hi.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So, can
you tell us a little bit
about how you got into design?
MARIE SCHWEIZ: I was
a front end developer.
I earned my little money
with HTML and markup.
And I tried to
get to university.
At that point, agencies
were too interested in me,
and I already got a
job as a designer,
because I had too
much talent for that.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So what was
your first successful project?
MARIE SCHWEIZ:
What is successful?
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Well, you
could also say challenging,
but I thought successful might
have a good story with it.
MARIE SCHWEIZ: My first
successful project
was, I think, on Android, with
a hacker community in Berlin,
Blinkendroid.
I helped them to
clean up the interface
and we had a world
record, I think.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
A world record of?
MARIE SCHWEIZ: They're
holding a world record.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: For the
hackathon, or maybe apps built?
MARIE SCHWEIZ: No, Blinkendroid
is an application where phones
build a huge mosaic
off tiny displays,
and they built the
biggest one, so I just
helped them to clean up.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Can you tell us
what the mosaic image was of?
MARIE SCHWEIZ: I think an image
of our hacker's base in Berlin.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: OK.
So not like the Mona Lisa.
MARIE SCHWEIZ: Not
like the Mona Lisa.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: All right.
But just as cool.
How many people participate in
the hacker community in Berlin?
MARIE SCHWEIZ: Oh, I can't say.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Because it's confidential?
MARIE SCHWEIZ: No,
not confidential.
It's too huge.
If you take, for instance,
the [? C base ?] in Berlin,
they have 500 members.
And from 500 members,
100 are active per week.
You don't know how many members
are actually living and working
in Berlin.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Got it.
And so, if a
designer were wanting
to start building for
Android, or just stepping
into their career, what are
some of the tips and tricks
that you would give a designer
that's just getting started?
MARIE SCHWEIZ: I would say, try
to befriend your colleagues,
because collaboration is
all you have to learn.
And very often designers stay
in their own comfort zone
and in their own space.
And the best you can do is
pick your colleague's mind,
and start learning about
the technology itself.
You don't have to code it, but
you have to learn what it is.
I think that's the best advice
I can give to young designers.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Yeah, I absolutely
agree on the
collaboration front.
Designers are integral
to the process
of creating a beautiful
mobile app, or, I think,
really any successful
technology project.
I think a lot of times
developers and software
engineers don't really know
that-- just how integral you
are to the success.
MARIE SCHWEIZ: A designer has
an empathy role in a team.
He is using a lot of empathy
to design and create,
and he's using empathy
to communicate.
So that's some sort of
part of our job, I think.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
And so, your talk
yesterday was a bit
about creating beautiful,
intuitive user experiences.
Can you tell us a little
bit about your talk,
and what you wanted the
audience to walk away with?
MARIE SCHWEIZ: OK.
I was talking about
animation for interfaces,
and very often I get,
OK, that's too expensive,
that's too complicated,
we should do it later
when time is left.
And my point is, that's
the wrong approach.
It's one of the most important
and powerful tools we have,
and it's not very
complicated to do.
And I was showing
the audience how
to do it with just
pen and paper,
and they shouldn't be afraid.
And I had a lot of
developers in my talk,
so I was encouraging
them to join the topic,
and be designers, and
do interaction design.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: One of
the points that you hit on
was, really, that
anyone can animate.
And I think that the
prototyping element
of what you were gifting to the
audience was really important.
I think a lot of people
can feel overwhelmed
with being an artist, right?
If maybe that's not
their first calling.
So, do you have any tips
of overcoming that fear?
MARIE SCHWEIZ: Yes and no.
Overcoming, being a good artist,
is something about practice,
practice, practice.
And I was just
recently asked, how
did you become as good
as you are right now?
And I just said, stubbornness.
Stubbornness,
stubbornness, stubbornness.
You have to practice.
That's how it is.
And all I can say is,
don't be afraid of failing,
because in every discipline
you have to fail.
And if you look
at great artists,
you can see they
had their time, too.
So look at them.
Look deeply and ask them.
They will encourage you.
That's what I can promise.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Do
you think that having
a more beautiful, well
designed, intuitive app
will lead to more successful
apps and, therefore, more money
for developers?
MARIE SCHWEIZ: It happened--
I just know that works.
This is what I would
tell my clients.
I just say, you know what?
If you want to have more
money, we need to do this.
That's just how it is.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Awesome.
No, I really appreciate it.
So I guess that's really
the pro-tip, right?
Incorporating design.
And I think a lot
of the principles
that you touched on yesterday
in your talk-- which
is online somewhere right?
MARIE SCHWEIZ: Yes.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: OK, great.
So--
MARIE SCHWEIZ: It's recorded.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: I think if
people look at your principles,
they too can incorporate
design from a prototyping side,
bring it into development,
and then, long-term,
they'll be more successful as
developers because of a lot
of the--
MARIE SCHWEIZ: Not
just more successful.
What I say is, throwing
all the technology
you have into your application
doesn't make it better,
and it doesn't make
it cheaper to develop.
It makes it more expensive.
I was picking on the
name "meaningful."
Make it meaningful.
As soon as you have a
meaningful application
and a meaningful design, you
can have less development time,
less cost, and still
the same success.
So it's, I would
say, optimization.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And
so, are you for hire?
Like, if people want to bring--
MARIE SCHWEIZ: I'm a freelancer.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: All right.
So hopefully the developers
of the world reach out to you.
Can you tell us
your Twitter handle
and where we can see
more about your work?
MARIE SCHWEIZ: I'm reachable
on G+ as Marie Schweiz.
That's how I work.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
What is your website?
MARIE SCHWEIZ: My
website is dvsty.com.
So my brand is diversity.
That's how I'm reachable, and
where you can find my talk.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Awesome.
Well, thanks so much for
sitting down with us today.
And thank you so much for
flying all the way from Germany
to be here at Big Android BBQ.
MARIE SCHWEIZ: It's a pleasure.
Thank you.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So, again,
this is Natalie Villalobos,
sitting here with
Marie Schweiz, who
is a successful, freelance,
interaction visual designer,
who's visiting us here
at Big Android BBQ.
Stay tuned.
We're going to have more great
interviews coming up soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]